[Music]
welcome to the british council learning
hub whatever future you see for your
child we see the same potential in them
that you do that's why we've introduced
the learning hub as part of your child's
primary plus english course it's a safe
and secure space online where your child
can enjoy doing activities and quizzes
set by their teacher so that they can
come to class feeling more prepared by
developing skills such as reading and
listening in fun ways before and after
class your child will have more time to
practice speaking english when in class
it's all designed to help them make more
progress and to help them feel more
confident and motivated let's show you
around so you can help your child use
the learning hub independently
first you'll find all the information
you need to activate your child's
account in your welcome email we have
another video to guide you through the
process if you need more help now
let's help you and your child find your
way around
once logged on your child will find the
module they're working on and press open
your child can click on about this
module to find an overview of what
they'll be learning this one's called
let's explore
it's all about how to survive in the
great outdoors
so let's get exploring your child can
find vocabulary grammar reading and
listening activities and games in each
section
we'll demonstrate a few to you later
first we want to show you the features
that give parents a window into the
classroom such as
your child's project
let's find it it's in section five in
let's explore your child is part of a
scientific expedition learning about
ecosystems in the desert
their task is to make a solar oven
this real life challenge will develop
their collaboration and critical
thinking skills
here's the thing all the activities
they'll do on the learning hub will
build towards this goal
next let's find your child's magazine
here it is in the resources section
this is what your child will use in
class with their teacher and classmates
there's one for every module
now let's show you how your child can
upload files
in some sections your child will need to
submit written assignments for their
teacher to review and feedback on
to upload a file they need to find it on
their computer and drag and drop it into
the file upload box
then click submit
all activities open in a new tab
once your child has finished they can
close the tab by clicking on the x in
the top right hand corner
now let's see how you can track your
child's progress you and your child will
find the progress dashboard in the about
this module section
together you can celebrate your child's
successes and encourage them with areas
for improvement okay
let's try out some activities first a
vocabulary challenge in section one
let's click on explorers equipment here
your child has 80 seconds to match eight
pairs of words and pictures
it will help them learn keywords
relating to the topic
next up a spelling game
let's click on geographical features
this game helps your child learn how to
spell key vocabulary using the image as
a clue your child will choose letters
from the alphabet below to spell the
word
they have 10 attempts to select the
correct letters
there are six rounds so lots of
opportunity to keep practicing
now it's time for grammar activity
let's click on sequencing words
this grammar activity will help your
child learn how to use words such as
before and after
it will also help them to develop their
reading and comprehension skills
there are eight sentences listed in the
wrong order that your child will need to
reorder to do this your child can click
once on the sentence they want to move
and then once on the sentence they want
to replace
they can click finish to see whether
they have made the correct choices if
not they can always try again
finally let's match sentences with a
picture story
it's time for some sean the sheep video
fun and more reading practice
let's find it in section three
to view the video full screen your child
can click on the square in the bottom
right of the small video
once they have watched the video they
can put the sentences and scenes in the
same order that they featured in the
story
to do this your child will need to click
once on the sentence in each box and
then once on the space below the
matching scene
they then click finish to see whether
they've chosen correctly
we hope this video will help you
understand how the learning hub will
help your child on their english
language learning adventure we're with
you both every step of the way